all right so flood kimitati
this comes from kendo
but
i might be good at kendo but he might be
good at kendo as well so when i go like
he goes out the way and
i get hit and about halfway through this
this sort of feeling of kendo
i have to quickly
turn on the spot this is the same
turning on the spot that the fifth
generation is the fifth imitation
so
don't do that
make sure it's still there so he has to
go around it
ah
all right it's pretty easy really
just confidence calmness
yuck
ah
don't
always put the thumb in
yup
if i want to be a bit of a bully
i can do that
i can make him bend
if i want to go please go past i don't
want to fight you
ah
i do that
it comes from the
fifth kim each other
the second one you have to be careful
it's nothing
like the tip going
wrong on the second king patchy
you've got to be careful you don't go
like that just to bring it to your hand
and then go in
too
slow if you go to your cage
up
this is like the roof of a house
yup
hey
this isn't very good
the chimney's sticking out
it's got a cover
ahead
ah
the biggest problem that i think you've
all got it doesn't matter how big you
are i think you're fearing it
i think you've got a bit of fear there
so
you don't know how to take it on
you can see me my eyes oh over my ken
when my eyes get
under my ken
that's when i'm safe
right
so that's when i'm safe
my can
this arm
that shoulder's got to be safe this
shoulder's got to be safe
so
the only thing i can tell you but the
trouble is i can't take away your fear
that's built in you as a human being
but even if you're too slow
if that bit you keep getting wrong and
most of you do
yeah
all right he hasn't hit me has he
supposedly he does hit me
ah
you know what you're fearing well you
might break my ken you see you're always
going to put something in your head
if he really hits it and i'm at that
angle i'd like you to just watch
where his ken goes does it go to the
right or the left
where'd it go that way yeah
why am i fearing
that's why you've done it so it
it did bounce
away if you do the more you do that the
more chance he's got breaking your ken
so you've got plenty of time
so if you want to try
this speed
and then
do that
then i'd say
that's the speed you need to start do it
at
i absolutely you're not supposed to
favorites i absolutely love this one
because it allows me
to get my hip to talk to my hands to
talk to my energy
it actually
i have to be careful because it actually
fuels my ego this one it fuels it
because i get such a buzz from it
yeah
see once i start putting the ego and a
bit of enjoyment into it power comes out
ah
hey
love it love it i'm not trying to win
against him i'm just loving whatever i'm
getting it's the you know the old buzz
but what i've had to do over the years
is
get that bit it'll take the fear away
from you
all right
do i go anywhere
no
you just saw my foot move
ah
i'm not going anywhere
most of you won't enter in because
you're too frightened of the impact
so if you can do it backwards but then
you've got no power
[Music]
so you've got plenty of time
as long as you make this roof of the
house
we don't spend too much time on it
um
let's just do it again
that's my intention
his intention is to get out the way and
miss it yup
all right so that's it it's all about
him pushing your buttons you pushing his